one of the things that you learn in
sports is that if you just get stuck in
your own training routine and not learn
from other people that you would never
become a champion there was a guy by the
name of Vince giranda and I saw him
doing an exercise a triceps exercise I
said this looks like a some kind of a
Mickey Mouse exercise Jesus Christ it
doesn't look like some heavy lift of
some sort and uh he says we'll just try
it so I was lying there on the bench on
my back taking this Dum build going like
this 20 times and take it over to this
side do the same thing over here the
next day this muscle here was just
jumping all over the place he was
absolutely correct I never ever thought
of that you learn from those kind of
experiences he did then apply this rule
with everything and so that's why I was
always uh rather more hungry for more
information more hungry for listening
rather than talking